welcome to this video playing other all
from Romania this is Romania going for
modern defense iya spice things up a bit
what maybe maybe I can do something like
that after a for going for quickie five
looks a bit down though they can from
the exchange so let's just get things
developed now after your 5 you can
probably take that's not very exciting
no it does not interesting
let this looks very much like a king as
in yen but the seaborne is not it's not
played yeah but as already mentioned
there is no see porn in the plane
yeah let's let's try to use this this
fact opening up the center quickly yeah
he's completely ignoring everything that
blacks doing okay I had some idea with
this but ok so I'm going to take here
right or yeah so the position has opened
up with the white having played the
weird movie form
yeah it should be quite pleasant for
black really i also have a look behind
can you play yeah exactly what Quincy
seven maybe Knight f6
Queen c7 Knight f6 this really adds it's
it's a tricky situation might be he
might be able to play that
I can take and give the check though
okay maybe do that that said simple
systems a continuation at least I guess
before I'm yeah of course I know and
then you fear for such a simple trick
coming great I mean white was already
outplayed him i'm jang after this this
very few moves and I ran into queen a 50
i play Queen a5 very silly that's really
very very stupid play by black yeah now
he has various ways to to win this 28 5
of course before very very very bad
yeah maybe he can just simply take the
exchange that's a theist okay once the
wants to do it to play play some fancy
stuff which is just worse than the other
thing but ok yeah i'm just a pawn yeah
this is not as clearly lost as some
other things ok starting ok let's take
here first
yeah I really shouldn't have reached an
end game it's not a good end game but I
think it could have could have been
worse really okay
maybe I get some counter play against
the beep on I have I have active pieces
now
ok take him
that's that's also quite good try to try
to get active going to take here there's
no no direct tricks though it should be
3 or something
hmm
time warning
yeah I have some some play but it's
still not great
check-check
check-check
ah ok what a game and he let me in again
and then I found her found the plate is
really badly what a game
no maybe I can get King to fo yeah and
checkmate him something like that I have
some activity still rupee 5 was very
strange move check
check check yeah black resigns yeah I
mean maybe maybe check I really already
was back in the game and then I played
again like I'm like a [ __ ] losing a
Tempe tempe campy check HERE Rukia fate
is good check i have three was possibly
yet I thought I have some activity but i
don't i don't have enough p.m. with the
route coming in it's simply it's simply
not not working but of course Queen a5
how can you play moon 85 I mean here
this really should be good for black the
computer is not convinced it only gives
like a slight edge it looks totally off
with G for wine and everything I did
have something better it will be for
probably not so Quincy 7 the night c 5s
what the computer scheming with an equal
position and equal really check yeah
this is just blundering that is he be
moving Knight f6 is not working I wasn't
sure in the game but this is not really
working
now this is good for black if I'm not
mated right away then g voice is just
weakening terribly here yes no he has no
central movie must take now on g8 and
then I'm coming with with those kind of
moves he probably really must play this
this move from 95 given given by the
computer this looks this looks ok are
getting the night to throw a good square
and maybe have some idea to support here
against the pawns and then I can play
various stuff f5 or something but i
overestimated this i thought black would
be better here already clear is that my
idea with taking and Queenie virus is
totally ridiculous after before check
and Ti is multiple ways but this is
probably em yeah this is sorry yeah this
is just just silly white take here just
take the rook end and get it over with I
mean of course I play night at five what
else is then then this isn't isn't
something great it's just a pawn that's
not good very much but okay if I play it
as stupid as I did I mean you can play
everything okay thanks for watching